un millier de malades à politologue
spécialiste du moyen-orient vous êtes
resté avec nous c'est donc un premier
revers pour le premier ministre nathalie
bennett avec on le rappelle un des gens
qui ont voté de son propre camp contre
ça dit quoi une coalition définitivement
très fragile
alors c'est une coalition fragile parce
que très hétéroclite
il faut quand même savoir que la
coalition formée par naftal idée nette
comprend des parties finalement qu'on
attendrait pas là les partis d'extrême
gauche notamment et puis bien sûr
l'islam et les partis flamands
je connais pas les skis la main si a
quand même en étant de jusqu'au-boutisme
idéologique chez ces partis qui explique
pourquoi même paradoxalement ils leur
rapprochement
maintenant en face à lui très puissant
il coude qui même sans la figure de
netanyahu qui conserve son aspect
historique
mais surtout ce que ça traduit et
l'impasse d'un débat qui est déjà très
vieillot ce qui porte sur l'identité
d'israël parce que souvenez vous il ya
quelques années il a eu un grand débat
très vif à la constate sur la question
identité juive en israël
et c'est là qu'on a vu le l'irrédentisme
de la droite dure qui est aujourd'hui au
pouvoir alors et pouvoir encore une fois
parce que il ya un clapet de
circonstances qui ont permis cette vie
retrait l'export notamment l'usure de
netanyahou les bons il faut quand même
bien une chose dont on parle de revers
certes mais ce gouvernement sur cette
question à l'appui d'une partie très
importante de l'opinion publique
israélienne
encore une fois parce qu'on sort d'un
nouveau stick des violences qui a créé
les très très grande méfiance à l'égard
des pays bien d'où l'argument défendu
par bennett que d'accorder la
nationalité israélienne à des
palestiniens et par simple 2% pour
l'instant le motif d' allianz le mariage
avec des arbitres l infortune lily
menace envers la sécurité d'israël il
avait quand même un boulevard
contextuelle pour passer cet argument
qui est celui d'une partie des 10 litres
est là aujourd'hui il faut être clair
merci merci mnm mènera d'abord été avec
nous en direct sur rt francs